a nightmare for any Android developer
involves losing their app signing key or
having their app signing key compromised
losing this key prevents you from
updating your published app while a
compromised key allows others to
potentially leverage your identity for
malicious intent since the security
provided by this signature is integrated
into the Android platform once the key
is lost little can be done that means
that developers have traditionally been
responsible for keeping their private
signing key both safe and accessible but
now you can let Google Play sign apps
and manage your keys for you in the
Google Play console let's go through the
app signing process with an existing app
after selecting one of your apps in the
Play Console app signing is available
under the release management tools
section after accepting the Terms of
Service you will see the app signing
page with details about how it works and
instructions on how to start using it
with your app if you store your key in a
Java key store the first step is to
download the PE PK tool you use the PE
PK tool along with the command given in
the Play console to create an encrypted
version of your signing key if you
aren't using a Java key store we also
have instructions for how to encrypt
your signing key from a plaintext PEM
file then you upload the encrypted key
file to Google Play using the Play
console now that Google Play has your
signing key you have to generate a new
upload key and register the public key
certificate for this key with Google the
detailed key tool command to do this can
be found under the app signing page then
you upload both key files using the Play
console in a single secure transaction
after uploading the required keys and
certificate click enroll if everything
is OK you'll see a page with deployment
and upload certificates and when
managing your release you will see a
green check on app signing indicating
that it is enabled for a new app you can
choose to have Google generate the
signing key so the process is much
simpler we highly recommend you use app
signing to sign new apps after enrolling
in app signing you will use the upload
key to sign all future updates to your
app Google Play uses the upload key to
verify your identity and will then sign
your app with the original app signing
key that newly signed app will be
delivered to users you may ask but I'm
still having to sign with the
what happens if I lose this key or this
key gets compromised no problem we can
revoke the key immediately as it is used
to verify your identity with Google but
isn't part of the Android platform
security model to have your current
upload key revoked you can contact
Google Play support through a web
support forum so when you use app
signing losing your key doesn't mean
that you can't update your app anymore
with a simple process you can generate a
new upload key and provide us with its
certificate so you can continue updating
your app access the Play console to
enroll your application and take
advantage of app signing today for more
details check out the documentation
thanks for watching
[Music]